now to the story of the week that i
really didn't expect to be the story of
the week
and that is the revolutionary change
in jersey numbers and it's not just
single digits available to
running backs receivers tight ends
defensive backs linebackers it's also
running backs 80 to 89 linebackers in 20
to 49. it's all sorts of craziness that
can happen
and miles i i look peter king was on pft
live this morning with me and he
he was apoplectic
about the amount of interest in this
story over the last month
but here's why there's interest football
is an
incredibly visual sport it looks better
on tv
than it does in person it's easier to
follow
and it's very very very visual
and the numbers at the nfl level have
been
in a certain range a certain type a
certain way
forever with some some minor changes the
most controversial change
in the past 50 years before this one was
allowing receivers to wear numbers
from 10 to 19. and i remember miles
i'll admit this i was like you when they
did it i didn't like it
i didn't like it larry fitzgerald number
11. i didn't like it
i i i still can't get used to it but now
i have to because we're going to have
receivers in single digits as well
potentially or in the 20s or in the 30s
that's the other side of this that whole
range is open for running backs
receivers full backs tight ends
linebackers defensive
backs so it's a big story and
the thing that makes it even more
fascinating tom brady after
the rule was passed we talked about this
yesterday he's complaining well why
didn't you complain before
the rule was voted upon and it's on you
tom if you're not paying attention to
the rule proposals that affect your game
but i heard today because one of the
things i've tried to find out and it's
been crickets from the buccaneers did
they vote
for or against this rule change so
i haven't been able to answer that
question but only four or five teams
voted against it
and it's just poetic
that the patriots were one of the teams
that voted against it
and i'm told coach bill belichick hates
it
so even when they're apart
they're still united in their
curmudgeonness
the old man bill and the old man tom
want us to get off their lawn
single get off my lawn i think he may
have said an f-word there to adam
feeling
but get off my lawn with your digits and
your single digits in your
20s and 30s and who's the mic number 22
is the mic this doesn't make any sense
and
uh i love it i just love it that
belichick is against it
well i love it that belichick is against
it too because it makes me feel better
about my stance now you know when it's
just tom brady you're kind of like
but when it's the best coach of all time
then you're like okay well maybe i'm on
to something here you know
i just the thing that really i think
offends me the most about it is the
running backs that can be 80 to 89 i
don't want to see that
i don't want to see that and nobody
should have an 80 to 89 in the backfield
i don't like it but patterson
you're a guy you know from the vikings
who's now with the falcons i didn't like
seeing it then
i'm not gonna like seeing it with any of
this other stuff oh i won't choose those
numbers
i don't know but i'm time on government
time montgomery
yeah he started as a receiver became a
running back they let him keep the
the uh receiver number well or like mark
baron who started as a safety and then
turned into a linebacker and
you got to say 26 why is this guy a
linebacker well he's kind of a safety
but he's also not really a safety
so you know whatever it is we just got
to get used to it
i don't know man i i think i like i said
i think yesterday i'm
in the acceptance part of this i
understand what it is that we're doing
but like it's basically it's going to be
a bunch of young guys really
that are going to come in the league and
then they're going to have these weird
numbers because the guys who are already
established
well they may or may not want to do it
will they mike
well and that's the next point if you're
an older player
for whom there isn't a significant
demand for your jersey
then you should be in a good position to
change numbers because
the more popular you are the more of
your jersey they have made
the more expensive it is to you
to change your number
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports